this is a Fox News Alert we're just
getting a statement from Virginia's
governor Ralph Northam about this
controversy there you see the yearbook
from 1984 here is the statement I'll
just read all of it from governor Roth
nor from Northam of Virginia quote
earlier today a website published a
photograph of me from my 1984 medical
school yearbook in a costume that is
clearly racist and offensive I am deeply
sorry for the decision I made to appear
as I did in this photo and for the hurt
that decision caused then and now this
behavior is not in keeping with Who I am
today and the values I have fought for
throughout my career in the military in
medicine and in public service but I
want to be clear I understand how this
decision shakes Virginians faith in that
commitment I recognize that it will take
time and serious effort to heal the
damage this conduct has caused I'm ready
to do that important work the first step
is to offer my sincerest apology and to
state my absolute commitment to living
up to the expectations Virginians set
for me when they elected me to be their
governor governor Northam a statement on
this photo and the yearbook we covered
at the top of the show and obviously in
the week in which he also commented on a
late-term abortion bill that many
critics described as in fantasy